[Music]
the guy was a genius when it came to
television he worked on the Mike Douglas
show he helped Richard Nixon when he
could watch television he knew what to
do to fix things and you said Roger Lu
went to mr. Roger critiqued me teach me
if you if you don't mind tell me what
I'm doing wrong what did he tell you you
were what what were you doing right and
what were you doing wrong he was really
really kind about it and you know it's
interesting that he I mean you know
somebody came to you about that and said
Howard you know more about radio than
anybody in the world help me get better
and I say do you compete with me
exactly I say [ __ ] you exactly right and
he did not and that's exactly what I
expected him to do I brought it to him
in kind of a Joshua like I meant it if I
made you worried he was going to give
you bad advice to undermine her you
don't wear a miniskirt that'll kill you
would he give me fake would he give me
deliberately bad advice would he tell me
no would he use it against me would he
got now then start telling people Maddow
came to me for help she's a disaster MSN
music you know would they be gracious he
was gracious about it and and
constructive and gave me some
interesting stuff to think about and I I
mean I know bra panties show or any of
that stuff there was no indication that
he wanted to know there are a lot of
people who are mad at me for saying
anything nice about him given the other
things that we learned about him before
he died but I do I'm not downplaying
those things to also be able to say
listen this is a true thing about the
way he interacted with me and he was a
friend would you have ever considered
working at Fox News if Roger said to you
look I like you I don't agree with you
politically but I think this would be a
good sort of mix you being part of the
Fox News team would you have taken that
seriously and looked into it he he once
told me that he wanted to hire me um at
Fox and actually this is not that long
ago within the last few years you told
me wanted to hire me at Fox many told me
he'd never put me on the air laughs Abby
would just fire me so Daniel can put me
on and put me on ice I was like so you'd
pay me a full contract to not work would
you consider that you know what who
would not consider isn't that fantastic